AMANDA SURYA: Hi everyone.
Welcome to our episode five of
the Women Techmakers series,
and this is Part One.
We are talking to an amazing
woman techmaker, Bettina Hein.
And before we start, let
me just introduce
myself and my co-host.
My name is a Amanda Surya, and
I've been here at Google for
about six years.
I started off as an engineer
here at Google, and then I
became a manager in the
developer relations team.
And I currently manage developer
relations work for
YouTube and our Google
Commerce products.
And let me hand it off to
Gretchen to introduce herself.
GRETCHEN HOWARD: Hi everyone.
I'm Gretchen Howard.
I run Google+ for brands, so
the business side of our
social business at Google.
I've been here about seven
years, and worked always on
the business side of the house
or in online advertising, in
particular.
So welcome again Bettina.
We would love--
as we said, you're the founder
and CEO of Pixability.
We would love just for you
to introduce yourself.
BETTINA HEIN: So, yeah.
My name is Bettina Hein.
I am the founder and CEO of
Pixability, and I'm a repeat
technology entrepreneur.
I started my first company right
out of graduate school,
as a spin-off of the Swiss
Federal Institute of
Technology.
And after that I founded
Pixability, which I founded
out of MIT.
GRETCHEN HOWARD: Great.
So just starting off, I would
love it if you could just give
us some background on how you
chose the name and just what
is the business model of your
company for those that don't
know about Pixability?
BETTINA HEIN: So the name?
Well, it had to do--
I was trying to find a name
that was, when I started
Pixability, that had to do with
video, but not too closely.
Because, as experienced
entrepreneurs know, your
company often doesn't turn out
doing the thing that you
envision at the beginning
that you'll be doing.
So we programmed the [INAUDIBLE]
program that
concatenated all these different
types of names,
words together to find a name.
And that was great, but none
of those were available.
So I found Pixability for sale
and thought, oh, this is cool.
Pixel, video, that's
kind of related.
So that's how I chose
the name.
But what Pixability does is we
solve YouTube for marketers.
So we basically make companies
successful on YouTube.
We help them get more views
and get more customers by
increasing their convergence
on YouTube.
AMANDA SURYA: Awesome.
I love the name Pixability,
and the story how you came
about with the name.
GRETCHEN HOWARD: Yeah, it's like
launching [INAUDIBLE],
just like we do it do at Google
here all the time.
So it's great.
AMANDA SURYA: So, Bettina, since
I work on YouTube and
I'm sort of familiar
with Pixability.
So Pixability offers this very
interesting feature called
online video grader, right?
Can you tell us more about that
and what sort of data
signals are you measuring,
in order to come
out with that grade?
BETTINA HEIN: Yeah.
So we have a free tool that's
called onlinevideograder.com,
and it's a way for companies
to measure how well they're
doing with video marketing.
At Pixability, we're also the
authors of "Video Marketing
for Dummies." That just came out
earlier this year, and so
we've put a lot of thought
into what makes an online
video successful.
And with the online video
grader, it's a free way to
check out how you're doing.
So you get a score between
zero and 100.
And it tells you how well you're
doing, in terms of
having video on your website, in
terms of how well you come
up in search, in terms
of how well you're
doing with social media.
And it's an automated tool that
anybody can use for free,
and helps them also improve
their score.
It gives you tips on what you're
doing wrong, what you
should be doing.
And it exposes a part
of our software.
It's a little tidbit
that is free,
that's useful for people.
To also entice them to maybe
sign up for the paid version
of our software.
GRETCHEN HOWARD: That's great.
So it's a teaser to get them
started and get them
interested.
I love it.
I'd love to hear more.
Sort of building on that, as
you you're helping these
businesses meet their business
objectives through the use of
online video.
How do you work with different
companies to understand what
the consumer trends are and
how to interpret that into
online video?
BETTINA HEIN: Well, what we do
is we have a software that
sits on top of your YouTube
channel, basically as channel
management software.
And what we help you do is we
help you analyze, first of
all, to start off, what are
people actually watching in
your topic space?
So we use these topic clustering
algorithms that tap
into YouTube's API, but also
look at Facebook, and Twitter,
Google itself, LinkedIn.
And we figure out, what
are people looking at?
So let's say that you are
L'Oreal, one of our customers.
And you want to figure out,
what are people watching
around dying their hair?
So we look at that.
We really look at, what
are the most popular
videos in the space?
How many of them are there?
What links they have, how
socially popular they are, and
how people are talking
about them.
All of that in the first step.
And then we help them with
a workflow tool, with the
creation of the video.
So making sure that they can
approve edits of their
production people,
whether they're
in-house or external agencies.
Then what we do is we help them
publish out those videos.
So they publish them to YouTube,
but then also share
them out on Facebook, and
Twitter, LinkedIn, Pinterest--
GRETCHEN
HOWARD: Google+ [LAUGHING]
BETTINA HEIN: Sorry.
But yes.
That's for the geeky types.
Absolutely.
So that's what we do, and
we help them also
optimize the video.
So help them optimize all the
metadata around the video, the
titles, the tags, the
descriptions.
And that's informed by this
data that we've collected
around millions of videos
on their video topic.
And then we help them track--
we help them in short length
so that they can track
conversions off of that.
We also help companies create
hyper-targeted add placements.
So we encourage them to
use AdWords for video.
We're big fans of that, of
the new TrueView formats.
And we show them exactly on what
videos, and what channels
they should be putting
those TrueView ads.
AMANDA SURYA: Awesome.
So, Bettina, what advice would
you give a company who wants
to leverage YouTube as a
marketing platform, based on
your experience?
What advice--
how do they get started if
they're new to YouTube and
they're new to Pixability?
And what advice would
you give them?
How do they get started?
Why is it important to
market in YouTube?
What opportunities are there?
BETTINA HEIN: Well, I think
they should read "Video
Marketing for Dummies,"
first of all.
[LAUGHS]
It's a long book that we wrote
about all of that, but it
really depends on a little bit
where they're coming from.
So we work with two types
of companies.
We work with big brands, but
we also work with smaller
companies that very much have
grown up in online marketing.
So for the big brand marketers,
what I tell them is
that TV is dead.
They really have to--
their audiences--
if they are marketing to
a youth demographic.
Or even not so young people
anymore, they have to do
online video.
And YouTube is where things
are happening.
It's three times larger
than any other public
video network out there.
So we do a lot of work doing
evangelism for YouTube.
We know that young audiences
don't really bother with live
TV anymore.
A lot of them don't.
Often times, it's
very nonlinear.
It's all YouTube,
Netflix, Hulu.
And so we get the brand
marketers to understand that.
That their 30-second commercials
is really not what
is useful anymore.
If you're talking to online
marketers, the conversation is
a slightly different one.
It's more around,
you're already
doing Facebook marketing.
You already have a blog.
You're doing all of this
online content.
You should also be
doing video.
So those two sort of are
converging, those two lines.
And what we tell people is
that YouTube is really as
large as Facebook, in terms
of unique viewers a month.
I think you have about 150
million unique viewers.
Facebook has 158.
So not a big difference there.
And we see that there is a lot
of arbitrage to be had, to
speak in financial terms
a little bit.
TrueView and AdWords for video
right now is a great
opportunity to get an audience
that you'd otherwise not be
reaching at super prices, better
than you can get with
regular AdWords.
So we tell people to think about
the content that they
should be creating, but also
thinking of augmenting that
content creation with
some paid spend.
GRETCHEN HOWARD: So it sounds
like everything from helping
businesses drive brand awareness
to acquiring new
customers, to really deep
engagement you focus on.
It's really interesting.
BETTINA HEIN: Yeah.
Yeah.
We basically run the gamut
with our software.
There are companies that are
focused on the Facebook
platform, like Buddy Media.
We're very much focused on
the YouTube platform.
And just help companies and
marketers understand that from
A to Z.
GRETCHEN HOWARD: Great,
really important.
I would love--
in your intro you talked about
that you're a repeat
entrepreneur.
I would love if you could
talk about the
first company you created.
I think it was a
speech company?
That would be great just to
understand that background and
sort of what has led you
to build companies.
BETTINA HEIN: Well I've
never had a real job.
So I like to say that.
I like to brag with that.
I started my first company right
out of graduate school,
and it was a spin-off of the
Swiss Federal Institute of
Technology in Zurich,
Switzerland.
And we were a text-to-speech
software company.
And I'm proud to say that today,
over half a billion
people interact with
our technology.
We are the text-to-speech
in Google Android.
We're in Google Translate.
We're in most premium cars in
the world, in the GPS system.
So the voices that speak to you
there, that is my first
company's technology.
So I started that company with a
bunch of engineers from ETH,
the Swiss Federal Institute.
And we raised $8 million
in capital for that.
And we sold it for
$125 million and
made 11x for the investors.
So made people lots of money.
And so afterwards,
I thought, OK.
I'm going to do this again.
I'm going to try this
one more time.
And in the second company,
Pixability is somewhat related
to what we did at SVOX.
It's also software, obviously,
but SVOX was very much heavy
text analysis.
And so we use text analysis also
in the algorithms that
create the recommendations
for Pixability.
So there are some commonalities
between those
two businesses.
And, yeah.
I just love being
an entrepreneur.
I come from an entrepreneurial
family.
All of my four grandparents,
my grandmothers, my
grandfathers were entrepreneurs
in their own right.
And I never had anybody in the
family that had a nine-to-five
job, so I really don't
know what it's like
to do anything different.
GRETCHEN HOWARD: At least your
children will know what
they're going to be when they
grow up then, long history.
[LAUGHING]
BETTINA HEIN: Or my little
daughter, Louisa, she may
rebel against it all and
become a civil servant.
AMANDA SURYA: Or a Googler.
BETTINA HEIN: Well that's an
entrepreneurial company, as well.
I mean, you're much bigger
now, but yeah.
I mean it's--
GRETCHEN HOWARD: I love that
we use your technology, and
Android, and Translate
and everything.
I mean, I probably have used
your technology three times
today already.
So it's great to see
that intersection.
BETTINA HEIN: It makes me
so proud, you know?
And I'm very grateful,
obviously, to Google for
making that possible, for
integrating that and being
part of my entrepreneurial
life story.
AMANDA SURYA: And,
in both of them--
SVOX your first company, that
came out of a research
project, I guess, right?
It was spun-off, so it was a
research project that you were
doing, right?
And then Pixability, was
that the same case?
Because you were coming
out from school too.
BETTINA HEIN: --at MIT.
Yeah, exactly.
I was writing my thesis on
business of software at MIT
and was looking for
my next thing.
I'd already done the first
company and was taking a step
back, trying to figure out what
had just happened to me.
Being a tech company founder
is a very intense thing.
And you really have
your head down.
And you're working really hard,
and you don't think
about anything else.
It's like, day and night.
That's all you do.
So then I had this chance to
go to MIT for a year and
really reflect on what had
just happened to me.
What is this train that just
hit me of technology?
So I actually was able to
reflect a little bit on how
technologies get adopted, and
why it takes such a long time,
and how technological
construction works.
And I wrote a thesis about how
hardware and software are
integrated these days, and how
that makes a large difference
in value creation.
So I had some time to reflect.
And then I knew that I was going
to jump right back into
a new venture.
AMANDA SURYA: That's awesome.
GRETCHEN HOWARD: Yeah.
It's interesting, too, that
you started one company in
Switzerland and one in the US.
Our developer network
is international.
What was some of the differences
of having the two
start-ups in very different
environments?
BETTINA HEIN: Well, in Europe,
I was born in Germany, and I
moved to Switzerland
when I was 19.
Even though my grandparents were
entrepreneurs, there's
really not this entrepreneurial
ecosystem that
you have in the US here.
So it was a dream to
come to the US.
It's really the classic
American dream.
I want to do a technology
company in the United States
and see if I can make it.
It's sort of like New
York, New York.
If you can make it here, you
can make it anywhere.
So that's what I was thinking
when I thought, OK.
Well I've done this company.
Now I want to try it
somewhere else.
And I decided to do that in
Boston because of the
geographic proximity
to Europe.
To be able to go back and see
my family, even though I did
consider going out
to California.
But I really found here a great
home in Kendall Square
for what I do.
And it's a lot less lonely
here, as an entrepreneur.
Specifically, as a female
entrepreneur.
In Switzerland, I didn't think
there was any other female
tech entrepreneur in
the entire country.
At least I never met anyone.
And so--
AMANDA SURYA: You were a
pioneer, pretty much.
BETTINA HEIN: Well I don't know,
I mean, it's very rare.
Technology entrepreneurs
are not that common.
I knew a fair amount of them,
because I already started out
of college.
I started Start, which furthers
entrepreneurship
among European college
students.
So I knew a fair amount of them,
but there weren't any
women there.
So when I came here, and I
discovered that there are all
these women that are doing
startups, it was great.
It was great to have
this sisterhood.
And so I founded a group called
the SheEOs that I run
sort of as a hobby, where we
have 130 female CEOs in the
Boston area, that come
together every month.
AMANDA SURYA: I love the name,
by the way, SheEOs.
That's really creative.
And why do you think it's
important to gather and form a
network of other women,
entrepreneurs and leaders?
BETTINA HEIN: Well as female
entrepreneurs we have, often
times, a little bit different
backgrounds than the typical
male founder.
We have slightly different
networks.
And so we may not
be tapped into
everything that's happening.
Our conversations are often
slightly different than the
ones that the guys have.
I'm going to be stereotypical
here, but they're probably a
bit less sports-related.
Or we might be less into
first-person shooter games.
That kind of stuff.
So there's a little bit less
natural bonding going on
there, between the female
entrepreneurs and the male
counterpart.
I can talk a good game for
sports and all of that.
I've learned to do that because
I've work with men
most of my career.
But with women, it's a different
conversation.
And what we do at the SheEOs,
it's kind of a let your hair
down event.
Everybody can be open about
what they're doing.
And women are very
collaborative and like to share.
And they're relatively honest.
There's a lot less posturing
around I'm this cool guy, and
I'm cooler than you.
So we get to the bottom of
things pretty quickly, and
people will reach
out and help.
So that's why I think it's
important to do that.
I just think SheEOs offer a form
where women can do that.
GRETCHEN HOWARD: I think
that's so great and so
important that you're helping
create a network like that.
One of my favorite quotations is
from Madeleine Albright who
says, "There is a special place
in hell for women who
don't help other women,"
which I love.
And I think you're representing
that really well.
So, in that vein--
whether in this forum, or
outside of it-- what is the
best advice that you've been
given to help you succeed?
It could be in your personal
life or professional life.
And what advice do you give
other young entrepreneurs?
BETTINA HEIN: Well so my--
one of the best pieces of advice
that I ignored the
first time around was by my
grandmother, who had had her
own little grocery shop.
And she founded it to help
support the family.
And she told me when I started
my first company--
she said, Bettina,
you know what?
It's going to take a while for
you to get this established.
Three or four years until you
really see it coming together.
And I said--
the dutiful granddaughter--
I said, yes, Grandma,
and smiled.
But I thought in my head,
Grandma, I'm starting a
technology company, a
software company.
We're going to go like this,
this hockey stick curve.
Well, little did I know, that I
would be going to work every
single day for years.
It seemed like an eternity
thinking,
why am I such a loser?
Why am I such a loser?
And why is this company
not working?
And everybody can figure
out how to make money.
I just can't.
So I really then--
and, luckily, my Grandma was
still alive when I was able to
tell her, well, Grandma, your
advice was very correct.
And, after three or four years,
magically, it started working.
We got traction, all of that.
So my advice to everybody is,
listen to your grandmother.
They know more than you think.
[LAUGHING]
AMANDA SURYA: So, basically,
listen to your grandma, stick
to what you're doing.
It takes perseverance to make
a company successful.
BETTINA HEIN: Absolutely.
I tell tech founders--
I have this thing I
like to get back.
Every week I have this
entrepreneurial office hour
where anybody can come
and talk to me.
But I talk about that being
an entrepreneur
only needs three things.
What you need is chutzpah.
And first of all-- actually the
first thing that you need
is naivety.
So that's the very
first thing.
You have to be kind of naive
about what you're doing,
because if you knew what was
going to happen, you would not
create this company.
And then the second thing that
you need is chutzpah.
You have to have, really,
the audacity to put
yourself out there.
And just tell people, this
is what I got to offer.
Tell me if you like it.
Tell me if you don't.
And the third thing
is perseverance.
So you've got to
see it through.
It is going to be harder
than you thought.
And you just have to
keep on going.
And fake it till you make it.
[LAUGHING]
GRETCHEN HOWARD: I love that.
And creating that contagious
enthusiasm
around what you're doing.
It sounds like you've done
a great job of that.
And how have you helped your
company, and others, and
yourself, get through
some of those low
points that you mentioned?
To really make it through to
that four-year mark or
whatever that mark is, where
you could go back and tell
Grandma, hey I really
made this.
How did you get through
those low points?
BETTINA HEIN: You have to have
a good team around you.
You have to like
coming to work.
If you don't like your
co-founders.
If you don't like your team, and
you don't like hanging out
with them, then it's going
to be really hard.
You also have to kind of
understand that there is a
thing called the
entrepreneurial roller coaster.
That one day you will
be high as a kite.
Everything's wonderful, you've
signed on new customers.
Investors love you, yay!
The next day, some customer
will say, this is useless.
I'm not buying from you.
Another investor will say, no.
An employee will leave you.
All of those things are
going to happen.
And it's going to happen
in very fast cadence.
GRETCHEN HOWARD: Sounds
like Google.
We have that same product
development cycle and
interaction with customers.
BETTINA HEIN: Well you're
probably still a young
company, in that regard.
So if you understand that, it
helps you just keep the faith
and hold out for that success.
I guess you have to be, also,
a pretty emotionally,
psychologically stable person
to be able to do that, to
really see a tech company
through its lifecycle.
But, yeah.
Just surround yourself with
others that are doing it.
Because you'll see that, if you
just read TechCrunch, you
think everybody else is
killing it except you.
But if you really talk to other
entrepreneurs that are
in the midst of doing things,
and buy them a beer, then
you'll hear the real story.
AMANDA SURYA: That's awesome.
I mean, that's really valuable
advice for me and our
audience, as well.
And I think, unfortunately,
we're sort of out of time.
And I just want to thank you
again, Bettina, for joining us
from Cambridge.
And it's been really great to
just talk to somebody who's
actually building a company and
innovating on top of our
APIs and platform.
I think that's really, really
cool, And shows a story that
you can be successful--
GRETCHEN HOWARD: Twice over.
AMANDA SURYA: Twice over.
GRETCHEN HOWARD: And
I think you're also
doing a great job for--
a great role model for all
developers out there and
entrepreneurs.
But especially women,
in particular.
So thank you so very much
for joining us.
BETTINA HEIN: Thank you very
much, and I really love the
dev relations team
over at YouTube.
So thanks--
AMANDA SURYA: Great to hear.
BETTINA HEIN: Yep.
You help us a lot.
So thank you for doing a
great job over there.
AMANDA SURYA: All right.
GRETCHEN HOWARD:
Thanks so much.
AMANDA SURYA: Thank you.
BETTINA HEIN: Bye bye.
GRETCHEN HOWARD: Bye.
AMANDA SURYA: Talk
to you later.
[MUSIC PLAYING]